- I heard that you...
Are you really big into ASMR
right before you go to bed?
- I'm into ASMR all the time.
(audience laughs)
Like it's really-
- Like chips, or like what do you do?
What are you-
- For me, it's the whispers and the like-
- [Kelly] That's not creepy to you?
- I know, so many people
have said that it's creepy.
Like I remember when I was with Shawn,
I would show him, and he'd be like,
"That just like grosses me out."
Because for me, it's
really about the saliva.
Like I like the sound of it.
- Oh my god.
- Like I like this.
For me, it's like when it's like this.
I'll show you.
Like when they're like,
"Today, (glass clinks) we're gonna do..."
(audience laughs)
(smacks tongue) Like I like that.
(Kelly scoffs)
I know. I'm sick.
I'm sick.
- I don't mind the tapping or
even the sipping of something.
But when it...
Yeah, there are certain
sounds I'm not into.
- [Camila] Right.
- Like I don't like the sound of kissing.
Like if you're like,
"Why did the audio guy
do that in the movie?"
- Yeah, I get that.
- Like we didn't need to
hear all that heaviness.
- Today, I was actually...
The one sound that does that
to me, today, I was driving.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, I have long nails,
which I usually don't have long nails,
I hate the sound of nails on a seatbelt.
- Seatbelt.
Yeah.
- Like today literally I was
driving and I was like, "Ugh!"
Just making myself so mad.
Like just hearing it.
(Kelly laughs)
Like that's the only sound
that does that to me.
But anyway, I love ASMR.
If I'm like stressed, it really calms me.
And I usually click on the ones
that are like "Giving
you a facial," or like...
They're like role play ASMRs.
This is sounding more and more-
- Like something else?
- Like something else.
No, they're actually...
There's no-
- Can you fix my plumbing?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly] It's sounding different.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
(audience laughs)
No, there's actually...
It's not like a sexual thing at all.
- No, no, no. I know.
I used to make fun of, actually
you have a friend in this,
Gwen let it out of the
bag one time on The Voice,
that Blake listens to it before bed.
- [Camila] Right.
- And he was like, "I don't know
that I wanted everyone to know that."
"Well, you're welcome. I'm
telling the world now."
(audience laughs)
But it was just so funny.
I was like, "You listen to
ASMR before you go to sleep?"
Apparently it's a thing
a lot of people do.
- But sometimes I'm like also
it really is, I feel like,
some people get the tingles
and some people don't.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I really get the tingles.
Not here.
- I create stories.
- Here.
(audience laughs)
(Camila laughs)
- See, now when you find the ASMR
that promotes the tingles
elsewhere, let me know.
(audience laughs)
- That's called a vibrator (laughs).
- (laughs) So, no. I just love that.
I go into story mode.
I can't listen to something.
And then I'm like intently,
and I go into like seeing
everything visually in my head,
so I can't do it.
- Oh, I get that.
Well, I watch them too.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Like I watch it.
It's a video.
Like okay.
- Oh, I thought people
more listen to them.
Oh.
- So there is listening,
and then there's also
like the YouTube ones,
where the girl's talking to you
and she's giving you a facial.
And she's like, "This product
has 20% glucosylceramide.
- Oh my gosh.
- And I used to...
I was like...
It's funny 'cause when I
would do anything like that,
like when I got a facial for
the first time a few years ago
or whatever, I was like,
"I'm getting the head tingles
with the whisper speaking
and the explaining of the products."
- [Kelly] Yeah, you're
getting soothed. Okay.
- And then I was like, "Now,
there's a whole name for it.
It's ASMR, and it's a whole thing."
- People have found it's a
whole booming job opportunity
(laughs) I feel like at this point.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- It might be like what
I do after this album.
(audience laughs)
- (laughs) You should've incorporated it
into this new album.
- I know.
- What a loss of opportunity.
- It really...
Yeah, I might just do an ASMR.
But I wanna receive it.
I don't care about.
- You don't have to put it out there.
- I keep making this sound really sexual.
(audience cheers)
- I wanna say one of your
lyrics is, "Asi es la vida."
- Ooh.
- "Asi es la vida."
- Mamacita.
- Thank you, Duolingo.
- Yes.
- Which means, "That's just life."
- [Camila] Yes.
- So where did you get this phrase? Why?
- So my mom has always said that to me.
Just like whenever I was like...
(audience cheers)
My mom (laughs).
I didn't see the picture,
and I was like, "They're really excited
about my mom saying things to me."
- They're like, "Your mom is amazing."
(audience cheers)
- You have like the nicest audience.
- I'm telling you, I do
have the nicest audience.
I will say it has
something to do with you.
- Oh, that's so nice.
- No, but so she just says that to you?
Is that something-
- Whenever I've gone through heartbreak
and been like, "I don't know,
I'm never gonna be in
love again, (vocalizes)."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She's like, "You're saying this now,
but cut to like two years from now,
you're gonna feel the same
way about somebody else,
and that's just like the cycles."
- And something that's like
this big will become smaller.
- Totally. And just like the cycles,
and not even just pertaining
to love or relationships,
but just being like
you're in a bad place now,
three years from now,
you'll be in the best place.
And then that's just that
life has these ups and downs,
and "Asi es la vida,"
that's the way life is.
- Oh. That sounded good.
(audience cheers)
Asi es la vida.
That sounded really good.
- There's a lot of I feel like Latin,
like Cuban, Mexican phrases
like that that carry
a lot of wisdom, and I feel like
so much of this album for me,
like because I started writing this album
a couple years ago, I
feel like with the songs
you could see from the
beginning of when...
Literally the first few
songs are like insecurity,
anxiety, paranoia, intimacy,
trust issues, whatever.
All this stuff.
And then like Bam Bam
was like the last song
I wrote for my album, and it's
me almost like internalizing,
it's me, I feel like,
becoming a grown ass woman.
- Yeah. No, I love that.
(audience cheers)
And it shows that healing process.
That kind of arc. I love that.